launch launch
launch this is the new Valkyrie drone
it's a prototype of a system that is
said to take out targets over a distance
of up to 3,000 M and run on artificial
intelligence the valkyrie xq58a could be
an important part of the US military's
multi-billion dollar effort to expand
its Arsenal with thousands of drones in
the next several years all so it can
keep up with increasingly Advanced
adversaries like China the Department of
Defense has been quite clear that
there's a concern about the conventional
military balance really shifting in the
indopacific in favor of China which has
more missiles and more people than the
United States and so to offset that
eroding conventional balance there's a
view that we need to buy more Next
Generation drones to bring Mass to the
theater and reset the regional balance
here's how the valkyrie is built for
stealth and how it could fit into the US
military's plans to establish a fleet of
artificial intelligence systems it's
really the only system flying
particularly that's been flying as long
as it has with Mission configuration
systems with autonomy with artificial
intelligence that's in the true a
tradable class range which means sub1
million fully integrated Mission capable
the valkyrie made by defense company
Kratos is designed for stealth missions
using parts that are easily sourced it
is still in the development process and
will have to compete with other AI
equipped drones for additional military
funding but within its class of drones
around the 5 to 10 million doll Price
Point Military experts say it's a
notable Contender we focus on a reduced
number of Parts obviously the fewer
Parts you have typically the less
expensive something is some of the
avionics are common with general
aviation aircraft some of the avionics
are custom and designed by us and by
some of our suppliers specifically for
the valkyrie it's the mix of all those
that allows you to have a system with
the capability level that this has but
without the sticker price of what
typically would be a man fighter
aircraft the valkyrie weighs 2500 lb
about as much as two or three Concert
Grand pios 30 ft long with the wingspan
of 27 ft it's made to evade radar
detection through its curved shape and
more specific features like the
serpentine Inlet that feeds its turbofan
engine the valkyrie can accelerate to
mock 85 travel 3,000 Mi at up to 45,000
ft in altitude and carry 600 lb of
weapons internally and the same amount
on each wing and it doesn't require a
Runway to launch it can fly from
aircraft carriers or small airfields but
one of the most important parts of the
valkyrie is what's controlling it it's a
combination of the AI with the features
of the aircraft itself that really make
it unique so think about the Vanguard
programs that the Air Force has rolled
out to say this represents the future
like adding uncrewed systems performing
man unman teaming performing multiple
teams of uncrewed aircraft together
and all of those proof of concept
elements have been demonstrated with the
valkyrie as it's evolved and in addition
to proving those basic concepts the
valkyrie evolved as a system so that it
can be a primary platform and system
that will ultimately be used to perform
those those actual missions the US
military has recently doubled down on
artificial intelligence to counter
threats from China and keep up with its
rapidly expanding arsenal we must move
with urgency and Unity of purpose to
ensure we can maintain the peace and
have our troops ready for whatever may
come because that's what's required in
this era of strategic competition with
the PRC while some military technology
already incorporates artificial
intelligence like computers that pull
data from satellite images or video the
military is exploring Tech with much
broader capabilities from inexpensive
drones with various intelligence
gathering sensors to automated missile
defense systems the military intend
tends to use these in such large numbers
that enemies can't destroy them all at
this point multiple branches of the
military and defense contractors are
working on AI pilot systems and they're
testing some with the valkyrie the Air
Force research lab conducted its first
test mission with an AI equipped
Valkyrie over the summer and shield AI a
contractor for the defense department is
working on its own AI pilot with the
Drone the valkyrie is designed to run a
variety of missions in contested
airspace its AI pilot would use a range
of sensors to Monitor and interpret its
surroundings the AI would share that
information and act on it issuing
commands to the plan's onboard computer
system which would determine the flight
path and settings to get where it needs
to go if the valkyrie locates a Target
it would get human authorization before
neutralizing it using bombs or other
weapons in a military operation the
valkyrie could execute missions
autonomously or be used in conjunction
with fighter jets because the valkyrie
can carry up to 1,800 lb pound of
payload it could also be used to launch
a variety of weapons but many military
experts have voiced concerns about
putting weapons in the wings of drones
running on artificial intelligence that
drones could inadvertently deploy
weapons that could cause harm or
escalate conflict there are huge ethical
and potentially legal considerations
associated with putting true artificial
intelligence in a drone in the United
Nations there's discussions about
banning lethal autonomous weapons of
course um but the problem with all of
this is that our advis Aries are
unlikely to participate in any kind of
ban on legal lethal autonomous weapons
and the United States in fact is not
participating in any kind of ban so the
real issue is that even though we choose
to act in a way that conforms with our
our values and um our role in the
International System other countries may
not choose to do that the valkyrie is
priced at5 to10 million that's a
fraction of the price of a crude
aircraft an F35 fighter jet can cost
about $90 million though in prac
practice many cost significantly more
but as the US military looks to add
thousands of AI drones within the next 2
years to its Fleet it will also be
exploring systems that are substantially
cheaper even if they don't travel as far
or as fast or carry as many weapons they
could use the same AI piloting software
being developed on the xq58a other
drones could accept some of the same
autonomy the basic Ai and the ability to
deploy AI across a number of systems is
very important and if you look at some
of the things that the Air Force has
published lately they've been very open
their intent is to have a family of
systems across the dod and to to
maximize commonality from an AI
perspective from an interface
perspective with those different
uncrewed aircraft systems so that it
doesn't require one specific trained
operator for any one aircraft type the
difference again becomes in the mission
capability there's still development
work to go in a test mission this summer
The Air Force research lab says an AI
equipped Valkyrie solved a tactical
challenge problem in the air but didn't
provide more specifics but whether the
valkyrie will move forward through
proposed initiatives like the Air
Force's planned collaborative combat
aircraft program remains to be seen
other companies are also working on
their own drones like Boeing's mq 28a
ghost bat according to Kratos the
valkyrie is already at a stage where it
could be used but full deployment is
probably at at least a year away because
the Department of Defense hasn't really
settled on exactly the types of drones
it wants to buy yet and in fact probably
needs a family of drones what you've
seen is that industry has responded to
this demand signal with this wonderfully
diverse set of capabilities that really
do span the whole Spectrum from the very
small to the much larger some of them
are focused on intelligence surveillance
reconnaissance some of them can carry
air to air missiles a real question and
the thing that industry is waiting for
is where is the that demand signal now
to scale production of these drones this
is an urgent question because we want to
shore up our Force structure in short
order to build up that combat credible
Force given how big a shift economical
AI equipped weapons represent for the US
military it's unclear exactly how or
when the valkyrie or the software being
built on it will actually reach the
battlefield